the deposed president of guinea no
longer a free man but under house arrest
after returning home from exile the once
feared leader seen as untouchable and
above the law is facing justice guinea's
attorney general ordered legal
proceedings against alfa conde and 26
former members of his government they're
accused of murder torture sexual
violence and the destruction of public
property conde's party members say it's
a political witch hunt
the rpg and its allies demand the
respect of the principle of presumption
of innocence and the depolitisation of
the current procedure consider
suspending its participation in the
national meetings recall the need to
appoint an international mediator in the
guinean crisis
it was only after conde was deposed in a
coup last september that the
investigation was opened for crimes
committed during his time in office
security forces
fired bullets at protesters in the
run-up to conde's contested re-election
in 2020. the 84-year-old changed the
constitution allowing him to run for a
third term
rights groups say at least 40 protesters
were killed and around 200 injured in
the months leading up to the election
guinea's military leader general mamadi
dombuya fired all 40 generals accused of
involvement in the killings he promises
a corruption cleanup saying the powerful
will face justice
but in a tv address on sunday he pointed
out that the free and fair elections
won't happen for another three years
while visiting west africa this week the
un secretary general called on guinea's
leader to hand over power to a civilian
administration immediately
the regional body ecowas has imposed
sanctions because of the election delay
dumboya's rule is seen by his critics as
a step back for democracy but conde's
arrest is being seen as a step forward
for justice in a country where impunity
for the powerful has long been the rule
nicholas hawk al jazeera